pas beaucoup de calculs de changement
climatique cet été mais cette semaine
trois études ont montré à quel point les
aux températures actuelles son unique
dans l'histoire récente ont décortiqué
la chose à notre chronique science avec
renault bonjour à nos besoins
renault on le voit d'ailleurs un peu
partout dans le monde et c'est quelque
chose qu'on n'avait pas assisté au co
des 2000 dernières années cette
augmentation
évidemment la température et cette
profusion connais pas exactement
c'est en fait ces trois il ya trois
études cette semaine qui qui donne
aucune explication à ce phénomène là
elles sont parus dans la revue nature et
nature geoscience
et elle montre que les changements
climatiques qu'on vit actuellement son
très différent de tout ce qu'on a vécu
au cours des deux derniers millénaires
sont les remet en contexte faut faut
dire qu'on parle de changements
climatiques souvent c'est une histoire
de gros chiffres
donc on fait des comparaisons que le
climat actuel et est ce que la terre
vécu le climat de la taille des millions
d'années mais au cours des derniers 2000
ans y aussi eu des variations
climatiques dans l'histoire de la terre
ait eu des périodes de réchauffement des
périodes de refroidissement pour des
raisons qui sont totalement naturels
souvent c'est lié au volcanisme un des
vérins de c2c pin de ces périodes là les
plus célèbres ça s'appelle le petit âge
glaciaire
c'était une période de refroidissement
cueillons tu le 14e et 19e siècles donc
on voit que c'est très étalée dans le
temps mais aussi des périodes de
réchauffement dans l'antiquité eu des
périodes de réchauffement au début du
moyen âge et cette variation naturelle
loeb il ya certaines personnes qui
l'utilisent pour dire vous voyez les
changements climatiques actuelles c'est
pas si grave que ça monte ça va
rebaisser mais ce que les trois études
montre c'est que il ya un élément
crucial qui distingue ce qu'on vit
actuellement de tout ce qu'on a vécu par
le grand deuil c'est que les changements
que mairie actuelle c'est quelque chose
de global c'est quelque chose que toute
la terre vit en même temps alors
qu'avant c'étaient des phénomènes qu'on
se rend compte maintenant qu'ils étaient
beaucoup plus régionaux donc c'est sûr
que les études ont montré comment on
fait également renault peau évaluer les
températures sur une aussi longue
période
c'est vrai qu'on avait pas d'instruments
qui étaient là pour mesurer directement
à l'épaule donc ce que les chercheurs
ont fait c'est qu'ils ont utilisés des
carottes glaciaires ils ont utilisé des
carottes sédimentaires donc dédé se
retrouve dans le retrouve dans le sol et
utiliser des courbes de croissance
d'arman des courbes de croissance de
corail et ils ont récupéré ces données
lors d'un peu partout autour du monde et
ça leur a permis de suivre comme ça
l'évolution du climat
donc c'est sûr que plus on
dante en plus faut faire attention aux
données qu'on utilise mais ce qu'on a
dans ces études là c'est solide et les
chercheurs ont constaté que les
variations prix industriels les
variations du climat elle était donc
comme je dis régionales ça arrivait pas
partout en même temps si on prend le
petit âge glaciaire comme exemple la
période la plus froide au niveau du
pacifique c'était au xvème siècle
ensuite en europe tout au 17e et ensuite
en amérique du nord c'est au 19e siècle
donc ça s'étale vraiment dans le temps
alors qu'à côté de savait ce qu'on vit
présentement c'est quelque chose de
global 98% de la terre si on regarde les
températures les plus chaudes que cette
traite toute la terre d'enfants ont vécu
c'est au cours des dernières années et
son peux pas l'expliquer à cause de
cette variation naturelle qu'on a vu par
le passé et on voit de plus en plus des
changements autour de nous j'ai vu un
reportage dans le monde
on voit notamment les arbres en europe
souffre énormément de cette canicule
prêtre est tellement chaud en europe
l'an dernier
c'est un exemple qui est acs qui est
assez frappant mais vu que ça serait
peut-être d'année en année ça commence à
refléter une assez grosse tendance et il
faut dire que la hausse des températures
qu'on vit actuellement le quand même
aussi une plus grosse ampleur que ce
qu'on a vécu par le passé elle se fait
aussi plus rapidement donc c'est plus
difficile pour les espèces de s'adapter
ou de fuir vers des régions qui sont
plus cléments pour elle et en france par
exemple justement cette histoire de
forêt on a vu qu'avec les canicules à
répétition est en train de changer la
composition même des forêts donc seuil
de plus en plus d'arbres qui sont
habitués à la température chaude delà du
sud de la méditerranée qui sont en train
de monter vers le nord et pendant ce
temps laver des arbres centenaires avec
son habitude température en bottes 35
degrés qui pose plus lentement mais ils
peuvent pas s'adapter humeur et ça c'est
en train de changer comme ça
de quoi la composition des forêts
françaises à l'arrêt c'est un exemple
assez frappante c'est une nouvelle
espèce sadap ce n'est pas nécessairement
une bonne nouvelle renault c'est sûr que
c'est du cas par cas mais cette semaine
il ya eu une histoire qui était qui et
comment ça dont on a commencé à parler
qui me frappe particulièrement de
lentilles histoire d'adaptation au
changement climatique depuis 2009 il ya
une maladie qui causée par un champignon
qui s'appelle candidats auris donc soyez
salle a commencé à se répandre à travers
le monde c'est un champignon qui
multirésistants avec s'attaque aux
personnes plus fragiles qu'on retrouve
dans les milieux hospitaliers et qui
peut être mortelle dans 30 à 60 % des
cas d'infection heureusement il n'a pas
encore beaucoup mais c'est en train de
se répandre et ce qui surprend
c'est qu'un champignon de ce type là
habituellement c'est pas censé être
aussi problématique pour les êtres
humains ils sont pas capables de
proliférer l'intérieur de notre corps
parce qu'ils ont ils endurent mal notre
température corporelle de 38 degrés
celsius
mais la nouvelle étude que suggéré que
cette espèce là qui est en train
d'attaquer les humains aient pourrait
s'être adapté à des températures plus
autres à cause de la hausse des
températures qu est ce qui a entraîné
par les changements climatiques
ce et c'est ce qui fait que pour avoir
développé cette présidence à la chaleur
et donc par la bande
cette capacité d'infecter les êtres
humains c'est sûr que c'est une
hypothèse donc ça ne sert vraiment à
vous falloir un truc comme ça faut
confirmer avant de considérer que c'est
quelque chose de des tons mais ça
intéresse beaucoup de chercheurs et ça
pourrait aider justement à prévoir
qu'est ce que l'avenir nous réserve donc
envisager ce genre d'adaptation
inattendu là encore beaucoup de
préoccupations par rapport aux
changements climatiques merci beaucoup
redoute avec les expos